the nascar cup series championship won
by this man
who appeared on this show uh is a more
if you will fresh-faced individual last
in 2016
when he was barely 21 years old now he's
a 25 year old cup champion he is chase
elliot how are you how you been chase
man i've been good i've been been a
crazy couple weeks and
really been enjoying uh enjoying
everything that's coming along with this
what's your first racing memory chase
elliot what's your first racing memory
and after me i started racing go-karts
and i was
eight-ish um and i i remember some some
of those races
actually um so yeah and
been going at it for a while i'm sure
absolutely
and now you know here you are we're
showing a picture of you in your daddy's
arms as a little baby
uh now here you are carrying on your
your family's tradition
of winning the the big race winning
a championship uh what does it mean to
you
chase now that you have won it yeah it's
honestly
just incredible and i think a lot of it
you know
i really haven't had any time to myself
um since sunday
um so i'm really looking forward to just
sitting down and reflecting on
everything it's obviously a really big
deal and
um you know something that i really
am going to enjoy and and embrace and
uh don't you know i wish our off season
was longer and you could you could enjoy
it longer but just trying to
recognize everything that that it
represents
well i mean i don't mean to intrude in a
time
where you're you're looking forward to
being alone so let's act like it's just
it's just you and i and not
uh a nationally televised streaming and
radio audience
um the fact that you have in fact won
i mean after you you know you started
your career old for 98 uh and your
family name
uh also attached to to all of this
uh what are you thinking like let's just
linger on this for a moment if you don't
mind yeah
i think you know a big one i i've
thought about some of the past couple
weeks is really just
the road to that first win was was long
and
kind of bumpy uh at certain points in
time had
some great opportunities and wasn't able
to get it done so
i think some of those tough days and
some of those tough losses that
were a part of that journey i really
felt like helped sculpt and help
prepare our team and myself for for big
moments
like this this weekend and last weekend
so
uh you know when you're living those
those tough days you
you know it's no fun but to see the big
picture now obviously
all that stuff happened for a reason
what was it like celebrating uh
with your dad in victory lane chase what
was that yeah
so great to have you my mom there you
know they've
been a a massive piece of my racing
career obviously wouldn't be where i'm
at without them and the sacrifice they
they've made so uh yeah grateful they
were there and
you know we could enjoy that as a family
is there anything you could share
the conversations again yeah just a lot
of excitement
to be honest i mean just a lot of
emotion and and
you know like i said a lot a lot of
sacrifice has been made over the years
and
they've uh you know played a huge role
in this
so yeah there's a lot of excitement
shared for sure chase elliott here on
the rich eisen show the fact again that
this was done in a pandemic too
uh has got to be something uh for your
entire crew
um a reason to celebrate obviously
we're always looking for anything
positive in this crazy world right now
um what were the challenges that you and
your crew
went through this year to get all this
chase
yeah you know we just kind of kept
fighting you know i think about our
season and it was just a
you could write a novel i feel like on
our year i started off really good
i felt like we started the year as
strong as we've ever been
um in my cup career and i was really
really excited
had the covet break and and came back
and i feel like we kept that momentum
everything was going just as good and
then you know about a month after we got
back from the coveted break it seemed
like guys were
starting to get better and we had kind
of fallen off some and we
spent i thought the majority of the
summer months struggling
uh not running very good and just wasn't
really hitting on anything and then
about the time
the playoffs started we you know just
got better fundamentally
you know nothing over the top but just
you know
small improvements in different areas on
the car and
added up to the performance here
performance there and
had a couple good tracks um for us with
you know with martinsville and and the
robo you have having two good races had
a little momentum and
had a shot at it so it's just uh
everything worked out and then obviously
you know championship week comes and the
race comes and
two pre-race inspections don't go your
way you got to start from the back what
was that challenge like for you
yeah you know i i think having a having
your car balanced well and having a good
team around i
obviously can make up for for starting
in the back i mean the good news was we
still kept our pit pick
and so we had our our pit stall as if we
qualify first which
you know is a big deal and i really felt
like that that pit selection was
probably more important than the
starting position itself so
just uh went to work and luckily the car
was
in the ballpark and we could fine tune
on it and we did and
hit it right for the last run so can't
ask for much more than that
chase elliott here on the rich eisen
show just a couple of weeks shy of your
25th birthday how many
how many of these do you think you can
win let's go let's go let's start
counting
future here come on now i'm gonna enjoy
the heck out of this one man i'm not
even thinking about next year right now
but
yeah it's uh you know looking forward to
the holidays and
um you know thanksgiving and spend a lot
of time around family and friends so
enjoy it man i'm not uh i'm not getting
ahead of myself today
all right who did you hear from after
winning an all chase that uh
that might be of interest to people out
there curious
um you know it's uh
i don't know i mean i don't have i don't
want to name come on names
come on chase there is no i in chase
there may be one in elliot though so
come on now
come on tough but you know i i
to come home to what i came home to
yesterday it was really cool and
um got to share a picture from the
weekend on
on instagram and a lot of great support
on there too so
man it's uh you don't realize how many
people pay attention to this stuff
until until something like this happens
so really cool
really cool and grateful for a lot of
great support
anybody from racing history anybody from
other sports who reached out to you yeah
you know one one that sticks out i'll
share daniel ricardo reached out he's an
f1 driver
um you know and that's a discipline that
i certainly respect and look up to so
from another area
uh that's a cool one i'll share with you
guys and he uh
you know was kind enough to say congrats
now you know obviously a relationship
with jimmy johnson we know about but
what what what were his two cents
on you you winning as he's heading off
into the uh
into retirement here yeah you know
the cool thing about jimmy you know he's
just
the heck i feel like he was a big of a
fan
uh and and pulling for us harder than
anybody
and you know you don't see that much out
of competitors
and he's just one of those guys that's
just genuine and you know he
he was genuinely happy for us and you
don't you don't get that every day in a
in a person like him so just a good dude
and
and he was uh just so so excited for us
and
couldn't ask for anything more how heavy
is the trophy
the trophy's heavy the trophy is heavy
um
we were doing pictures and stuff and my
little arms i need to get in the gym i
guess i had to take some breaks
this is something that could definitely
work on your your traps you know
uh your your tries no it's a serious
piece of uh
piece of metal yeah i mean so
did it get its own seat on the way home
where is it well
you know i don't really know where that
thing went because oh come on i
it didn't come home with me so i'm going
to get it here at some point i i
guess they have to box it up and you
know they don't want they don't want to
get broke
so yeah well that's probably good let's
not break it well it looks like
something you could sleep in
honestly like you could tuck yourself in
the toilet tonight at night
oh my gosh so right now you chase elliot
do not know the whereabouts of this
trophy right now as you and i are
talking it's somewhere between north
carolina and
phoenix somewhere between the two i
would say a man did it ask do you have a
tracking number
i don't have a tracking number but i'm i
trust i trust the uh
the the people at nascar because i think
they're the last ones that had it so i
i don't think they're going to lose that
they've cut it around all year surely
they ain't going to lose it now
all right very good hey chase like i
said uh you were here
uh i know we spoke earlier this year on
the phone but
uh you are here as a 20 year old man um
about four years ago
um we're showing a photograph um of it
right now i look different you don't
but that's okay that's what aging in
this world really is
what if i told you on that day as you're
walking out the door you're going to be
the 2020 champion what would you said to
that
i said you're crazy um
man i just think about the beginning of
this road here in cup
and a lot of the things that have come
along with it you know i mentioned some
of those tough losses and
days leaving the racetrack ready to go
crawl in a hole and
you know to have things kind of
work out this year really is nothing
short of amazing and
um yeah just grateful for all the
all the lessons i've learned over these
first five years so
yeah things things can change uh fast i
suppose no doubt about it
and i guess last one for you is it fair
to use the word relief
as an emotion you're feeling yeah i
think there's a sense of that for sure
you know i've never
left i've never ended a nascar season
and been like
just fulfilled because you're always
wanting more right you're always wanting
to be the guy so if you're not the guy
you're not going to be fulfilled so yeah
i'm just
so proud and can enjoy
a winner knowing that there was nothing
else we could do
this year and uh that's
all you can ever dream of entering an
off season with
well congratulations man there's only
three father-son combinations to uh both
win a nascar championship lee and
richard petty
ned and dale jarrett and now you and
your dad the elliotts
congrats thank you guys i appreciate it
you got it you take care chase that's
chase elliott right here on the rich
housing show